so this is one of do Deniz famous
puzzles which you know still making
money to the Carpenters of Greece but
there's another one which is probably my
preferred puzzle of his and I've given
this puzzle to loads of people in fact
sometimes I given them to like
professors there's some really smart
people and it's not totally obvious how
to do it and this is a dudeney puzzle
it's very very simple all you need is 6
1 2 3 4 5 6 coins and the idea is to get
them into the hexagon like that you know
that's what you're aiming to get and you
must start from this ok and the single
rule is that you can move something
anywhere by sliding they can pick it up
slice lightly but anything you move you
can only put somewhere that touches two
other coins so you couldn't move this -
he - we could - here you couldn't do
that because it's not moving - it's not
touching - other coins so this one here
you can move it - there you could move
it to here you could move it to here it
just spit it has to be touching to other
coins and what I want I want you to get
from there to here
in three moves you can do it in four or
five moves pretty much straight away but
to get it in three moves does take a bit
of thought does take a bit of thought
and quite often you forget how to do it
so you could be on another train journey
and get it out and this puzzle here was
really the beginning of there are lots
of other in the genre of you've got a
certain amount of coins there in one
pattern you've got to make another
pattern and you can only do it by
sliding it to a place that's touching to
others what you don't want to do is lots
of people start like this they think
well I can do this but then this one's
trapped because you can't move that one
out because these two are doing it so
you you've got it and you can't take it
up so you can only do it by sliding and
you're not allowed to move any others so
the way that you would solve it just
remember on earth I did it is yeah you
put no you don't this is hilarious I
don't than this in a while and I say the
reason why I really enjoyed this puzzle
is that you you forget it's not that I'm
gonna find it we're gonna find it I can
find out this is like stage fright this
one goes here this one goes here I just
assumed people were doing this for
hundreds of years or that there was no
kind of someone actually it had to go
and invent it but like so many other
puzzles
this one was invented by a Henri owners
dudeney most puzzles try and almost
mathematical and logical puzzles try and
express some mathematical ideal to give
you some insight and there being some
puzzles that I have invented to try and
express some mathematical idea which
I've not seen before but what I also
have done which is what every puzzle
writer has been doing since the
beginning is that you have to rewrite
and adapt all the old puzzles for a new
age so you know I think the interesting
thing about puzzles is that we've been
doing pretty much the same puzzles for
last 2,000 years and and a good puzzle
is something that that goes viral people
want to share people want to either ask
how to do it or they want to see if the
other person is as clever as you and
this is something that with the Internet
has really shown that and I first
started writing about puzzles when I
realized how viral they could go and as
I researched it I realized that every
puzzle that I was reading from someone
was actually a rewritten puzzle from
someone else and then you can kind of
trace it back so being in journalists
really by profession in the book via can
you solve my problems I try to sort of
tell the history of how these things
work and it's a little bit like jokes so
jokes you know it's not often that
someone actually invents a whole new
joke especially what they're doing is
they're retelling that joke you know
with the few new words in it and the
intonation is a bit different puzzles
are exactly the same that they are
they're like a living thing and they can
they carry on going and they get better
in the retelling hi there everyone
thanks for watching do you have a coin
to hand if so why don't you toss it if
it comes up heads click on the left for
our coin playlist and if it comes up
tails click on the right
that's an objectivity video about a
whole box of puzzles featuring Matt
Parker so these are very much loose
papers Oh exactly as they were presented
to the Royal Society so there's a lot of
very miscellaneous material in here if
you haven't got a coin well just choose
I guess